ora tutti ragazzi ovviamente questo
video sono la vj oggi siamo sul mio
divano e questo non è un porno
giuro siamo su fallout ragazzi che un
videogame figo melo lo sto giocando in
questi giorni faccio che giocarlo mentre
registro perché la cosa mi figlia un
sacco nel caso vi steste chiedendo
perché sono nudo questa è la spiegazione
oggi che a stupenda di fallout che con
il completo da reietto che sarebbe
questo qui ciò addosso o 6 7 e 15 mentre
con questo scassinatore braccio sinistro
indurito o 87 15 quindi di più di prima
ed è così sono a nudo o solo uno
spallaccio come cazzo fa essere più
efficace questo che quello di prima ecco
questo è vabbè avete capito terai nudi
godetevi la vostra ultima ora
ma conti sta parlando che cazzo ma
[ __ ] la caf bravo cane o dio è
morto un cane
e morto il cane ragazza non è vivo il
cane di superman bravo cane vieni quadri
casomai eni quartini qua la star dove
vai
mi stai evitando avoca scambia cosa
scambio è un cane mi dispiace si
scambiamo qualcosa di un cane è
interessatissimo quello che stai dicendo
zio crediti pianoforte che davis con ebi
poterà i nudi da queste parti chiamiamo
la tua pettinatura straordinaria con via
la mia pettinatura zio non so se te ne
sei accorto ma c'è una maschera che
cazzo di capelli veri john anche azzurre
john travolta voi voglio vedere come mi
taglio i capelli con la maschera sono
curioso
sono curioso a se l'è tolta spiegami per
quale motivo dovrei scegliere il taglio
calvizie incipiente cos'è è illegale in
45 stati statale questo e vas di far cry
che cazzo ci entra insegnante di
matematica solo quello di matematica
accessi capelli quello di fisica c'era
diversi ragazzi se io ho un dito di
capelli cerasa tissimo come cazzo fan
parrucchiere a farmi diventare così non
ne avevo da che non ne avevo il soul
diventato così da me li faccio così
ragazzi appena esco esatto sunnita
quanto è utile è stato molto utile amico
mio hai visto che figo il nuovo taglio e
non sono un gran figo alle takahashi e
di takashi ma che fa schifo ma no che
sia un robot giapponese
raccontami una barzelletta
ma sono giapponese cosa chiede a san
gennaro sono vestito non sono più nudo
ma chi è no non voglio andare a scuola
al meglio andare a scuola stavo
scherzando per una verifica e sorpresa
ragazzi una verifica soltanto grande per
andare a roma con di minchia bensì di
parlare ma manco mi sono cresciuti bassi
ma non ho mica praticamente preso per un
pedofilo
oddio faremo una verifica piu avanti ma
quando mai è successo a sta cosa cinque
anni di superiori
manco una volta è successo che può fare
ha rinviato la verifica ragazzi spiega
come avete fatto
mi scusi lei perché viene a scuola in
pigiama e senti ron weasley mente almeno
un jeans dio mio santo ciao
salve sono io sono famiglie sono
simpatico ecco lui il mio amico ve lo
presento sono qui da qualche parte ce li
hai dietro [ __ ] quanto efficiente su
tizio da 12 mila è che si fa in groppa
re dei cani bravo zio bravo venditi
utile alla vita
cosa vuole da me se ti sta sparando lui
che cazzo vuoi da me mi chiamo morte
cos'è cos'è
ma cos'è una tigre del bengala ma che
cazzo hanno mica le armi di ritorno al
futuro calcio nei [ __ ] un robot
serva molto minister palle d'acciaio
ma cos'è ma è uno stupro bastardino vale
toglietevi ma non vale per cos'è è certo
stuprate un nuovo in mutande bravi ravi
a prendervela con uno col pisello della
vostra taglia sto morendo che cos'è un
nuovo passo di danza dai pro wrestling
john cena porca [ __ ]
sono vivo per miracolo mica fammi
salvare che bucio de culo saltata una
mina in faccia al mio solito culo nei
videogames
andiamo cambia il carrello dell'auchan
ruggers dove cazzo è il reparto dei
salumi e filamenti non ho ma continua a
star fermo quando esci dalla porta c'è
scritto commonwealth che sarebbe tutta
la regione come se io uscissi fuori da
casa mia e invece di scrivere milano
ascriversi lombardia
capito [ __ ] che lombardi amiche un po
più preciso no chao cosa fai
le pippe involtino dolce mica come
ridotta la tizia non so quanto possa
essere buono si involtino credi camicia
di flanella e gene è la madonna a
distanza di anni si è sempre una gran
[ __ ]
oltre a jackie si possono sollevare le
cose mi chiamerà dimenticato visto che
noi siamo amici da tanto tempo ti voglio
fare questo regalo prendi tutto ragazzi
non lo capisco c'è qualcuno mi deve dare
una spiegazione ho trovato un'arma
piccola questa cosa qua bello una mania
che piccolo che si posso portarne la
scuola durante le interrogazioni ragazzi
avete presente le zanzare che ci sono
durante l'estate ecco a me una volta è
successo di trovarne ordinarmi più ecco
però questa non si schiaccia neanche se
ci cade sopra big shot esatto che cazzo
oddio scarafaggi radioattivi sono degli
scarafaggi che cazzo ti copri cosa fa sì
io sono degli stanno perni poi sparargli
anche così guarda il bridge rante cosa
fai
porca [ __ ] schiaccia lo schiacciano
bravissimo nicchia come non detto rega
per che cosa vuoi da me la granata eva
fan cuore dai è ancora lì la granata al
akhbar
cos'è
io o mio dio chi è il re che cosa ci
facciano ex sulle scale bravo o
finalmente uno che se la prende con lui
ma edizione che non serve una minchia
mi scusi buon signore non volevo
disturbarla mi piace mi piace a tutti io
gli è saltata una gamba mi sembra di
vedere un vecchietto che cerca di
scopare leziosi messo malissimo che
carta il servizio ottimo lavoro a chi
hai fatto tutto tutta calda ragazzi che
incluso più episodio è stata na roba
strana nel senso che mi sono messo
giocare di mio perché ogni tanto gioco
anche roba mia e ho provato a registrare
nel mentre quindi è stata una cosa un po
improvvisata per vedere cosa veniva poi
stato un esperimento tra virgolette però
sfigati ricordatevi che gli scarafaggi
che hanno schiacciati coi piedi non con
le armi
a meno che non siano grossi così però
quella un altro discorso che ragazzi
spero credo vi sia piaciuto è come se il
video più visto certo momento è un mi
piace anche a voce di facebook e come
noi video trovate la descrizione sapersi
di scrittori ci vediamo lo fa subito
ragazzi